not only is DeSantis getting hit from
from the left but he's even getting hit
from the right now and this kind of
shows you when you're over the target
you're going to get it from everybody
here's a tweet by Carrie Lake Harry Lake
of course I've had Carrie on the show I
consider myself friendly and myself
friendly with her she was the
gubernatorial candidate in Arizona who
lost she's still contesting the election
but she tweeted this out the kiss of
death Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
endorsed by George Soros My Hope for
it is
that Trump and governors DeSantis of
Florida
will Slug It Out for the Republican
nomination
Trump has turned into a pitiful figure
continually be mourning his loss in
2020.
big Republican donors are abandoning him
in trolls
sentences through ruthless and ambitious
he is likely to be a republican
candidate no George Soros did not
endorse Ron DeSantis I actually tweeted
at her saying you might want to review
it again but Ann Coulter
Ann Coulter who was a huge Trump person
the first time around who basically is
now anti-trump Ann Coulter was on Tim
Poole's show discussing uh this move by
Carrie Lake in this video basically
where they made it seem like uh Soros
was uh going after Trump and and
endorsing to Santos this one pissed me
off Newsweek writes George Soros prays
for Ron DeSantis rattles Trump
supporters and that's putting it lightly
I saw Gateway pundit wrote George the
kiss of death George Soros endorses
Rhonda Santos which he did not do let me
show you the quote because they actually
do have the quote in here quote DeSantis
is shrewd ruthless and ambitious he is
likely to be the Republican candidate
this could induce Trump whose narcissism
has turned into a disease to run as a
third party candidate that would lead to
a democratic Landslide and force the
Republican party to reform itself fake
news from Anne I just think it's stupid
to decide whether you like a politician
or a person based on who else likes that
person or doesn't like that person yes
so obviously Soros isn't backing to
santis obviously he might be saying some
actually quasi-truths related to what
Trump's move might be and wouldn't it be
and this is the irony of sort of
unfortunately what seems to be happening
to Trump right now again I like that guy
I like his kids there's a situation I'd
vote for him again I proudly voted for
him last time but this move where he's
so all in on trying to take out DeSantis
right now and putting out all of this
nonsense on Truth social about DeSantis
and by the way it's not working I mean
it's simply not working
um maybe the move is that really and
this would be the ultimate swamp move
for the guy who wants to drain the swamp
is that he will basically start a third
party after this his America first party
and basically destroy the Republican
party so this Democrats can always be in
power wouldn't that be some way of the
swamp actually using Donald Trump I mean
really just 5D chess 8D chess you got to
think about these things
things
[Music]